i i this
okay i was today years old when i found
that out
hi i'm sarah hyland i'm dylan sprouse
karen robinson i'm marcus rosner i'm
sammer salem i'm keenan lonsdale and i
star in buzzfeed's next feature my fake
boyfriend my fake boyfriend my fake
boyfriend my fake boyfriend but today we
are going to play a little game i'm
playing never have i ever
are you ready
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
i have used a dating app
i have i never felt the need to
get on a dating app i
have used a dating app but ages and ages
and ages ago i have actually
i was a young man i was confused
and i was lonely
i have
oh i do that yes i have i have sometimes
it's just
you gotta
take the path at least resistance or you
know take the easy way out anyone who
says that they haven't i would say is
probably a liar oh
i mean who has it
it's not intentional
i see it
and then i see something else
immediately i
am
a pretty good ghost
but i do it with love i will respond to
texts in my head
and then
forget and realize like go to text that
person like three months later and then
see this question i'm like oh i never
responded to that text message
[Music]
i have given a fake name to someone i
just met but um just more for the
purpose of uh
just fun and games with my buddies
oh oh yeah i do that all the time
i have given a fake name to someone i
just met
yes yeah i think
i've given a fake name before i think um
proceeding with caution then so
because i just can't think that quickly
so i
so i i don't i yeah
i mean it's a ton of different names um
i don't remember any particular moment i
do that quite often like in the girls
bathroom at a bar
and they say you look like
sarah hyland and i go oh no michelle i'm
so sorry the lion i said my name was
miles
for a while and then i eventually told
him i had to show my license i was like
nah i fully lied to you like completely
but i usually go by buddy we usually say
buddy yeah i'm buddy
[Music]
yeah i have i think i don't know
sometimes you miss somebody and you just
have the urge to let them know
we are getting very personal my god
i could never do reality tv i'd spell
all my secrets like this i have not i've
not texted an x out of nowhere
[Music]
uh i suppose
that i have once you're an x you're an x
oh well you know you'd see something
that reminds you of them and you say hey
look i saw that
i saw that movie oh yeah i have
definitely uh back in the day texted an
x out of nowhere um because it's great
fun i text my x's
a lot like not all of them but i like my
x's
cool
define x define x
no i
have not created a fake instagram
account at all i have created a fake
instagram account
[Music]
i think that time for that i don't have
fake insurance
i have not created a fenced up but there
have been times where i almost have but
then i think what what would i put i'm
already so open on instagram i have not
i think that's a lot of work for and i
don't even understand why to be honest
i'm more worried about the person that's
going through being like who's looked at
my story wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute when i look at people's
stories they can see that i looked at
their story
i
this okay i was today years old when i
found that out thank you buzzfeed thank
you buzzfeed we've learned a lot about
each other today or at least you've
learned a lot about me i've learned a
lot about myself and i've learned
nothing about you now make sure you
check out my fake boyfriend